the long-awaited sex abuse trial of
British socialite galane Maxwell begins
this morning here in New York Maxwell is
accused of recruiting and grooming
underage girls for Jeffrey Epstein's
alleged sex trafficking ring now she
denies any involvement in any of this
and she has pleaded not guilty mola
lenghies at the federal courthouse here
in Manhattan with more on the story mola
good morning to you
well good morning Gail you know some
accusers describe Maxwell as being worse
than Epstein but Epstein's I'm sorry
Maxwell's family insists that she's
being made a scapegoat that she's taking
the fall for Epstein's alleged sex
trafficking crimes now you might
remember that Epstein killed himself in
jail back in 2019 and so now Maxwell
will do something that Epstein never
lived to do stand trial and face her
accusers
today we announced charges against
Elaine Maxwell galane Maxwell's trial
will focus on allegations made by
teenage girls from 1994 to 2004.
according to the indictment Maxwell
helped Jeffrey Epstein recruit groom and
ultimately abuse victims as young as 14
years old Maxwell is accused of
befriending alleged victims taking them
to the movies or shopping the indictment
says Maxwell's presence during minor
victims interactions with Epstein helped
put the victims at ease because an adult
woman was present Virginia du Frey is
not part of this case though she says
Maxwell recruited her in 2000 Acclaim
Maxwell denies she is even worse than
Epstein she was pulling strings she had
his money he had her contacts they made
a great group that way but healing was
much more conniving and smart than
Epstein ever was the alleged sex
assaults happened at Epstein's New York
Mansion his ranch in New Mexico his home
home in Palm Beach Florida and Maxwell's
home in London there are six counts in
this indictment the most severe of which
is sexual trafficking of minors if Glenn
Maxwell is convicted of that count she
may spend the rest of her life in prison
the 59 year old has spent the last 17
months at the Metropolitan Detention
Center in Brooklyn New York not far from
the federal prison in Manhattan where
Epstein died in August of 2019. his
death was officially ruled a suicide
Maxwell's attorneys have repeatedly
filed motions citing poor jail
conditions and unfair treatment I've
never seen anything like it she's being
treated horribly because of the
negligence and what happened to Jeffrey
Epstein the British socialite moved to
the U.S in the early 90s Epstein and
Maxwell whom Epstein once called his
best friend rubbed elbows with
philanthropists Business Leaders heads
of state and royalty but Maxwell
appeared to distance herself from
Epstein in the years before his 2000 19
death in a 2016 civil suit deposition
she denied knowing anything about
Epstein's alleged wrongdoings it's
unclear if Maxwell will take the stand
most defense lawyers would say that
Glenn Maxwell under no circumstances
should testify in this case
was trials expected to last about six
weeks the first four weeks the
prosecution will lay out their case at
which point it'll be turned over to
Maxwell's defense scale
thank you